[Music]
okay everyone
i am truly honored today to be joined by
emmy award winning and academy award
nominated
director and writer and showrunner of
veep
and avenue 5 armando iannucci how you
doing today armando
i'm very good i'm self-isolating i'm
living in
the attic in my house i came into
contact with someone who tested positive
so
over here i i i know
i know how to keep to myself for 14 days
oh wow okay
um it's just nice to talk to someone
really well i i hope you stay safe and i
hope the best for you um
no i'm feeling okay i'm sitting okay
okay good so
i'm on day four here well at least
during your
your quarantine you have this big now
digital release of your newest film that
you've directed and co-wrote the
personal history of david copperfield so
my first question about this film
armando is
why now in your career did you decide to
do
something on a charles dickens novel
what was kind of drawing you to this
um several things i've always been a
huge and
lifelong fan of charles dickens um i
think we have him down in our head as
someone who
was a sort of long-winded victorian
novelist who wrote
stuff about um fog and mud
and child's poverty was in fact
he's really very very funny very funny
and actually quite modern and there's
something about
this story in itself david confield
which is very modern it's about someone
growing up wondering whether they fit in
get into society what people make of him
i i think we'd have phrases like status
anxiety and
imposter syndrome to describe it now but
you know this is what was going through
him
in the 1840s it felt to me like a very
modern kind of experimental novel it's
all seen through david's own
eyes and you know it starts with him as
a baby in a chapter of words of kind of
like
one sentences of one word and words of
one sentence
trying to describe smells and shapes and
people's faces
and and things like that you know a lot
of dickens adaptations
very reliant they kind of emphasize
the plot and they don't pay attention to
the comedy or to the
imagination or to the language and the
the great fantastic dialogue and amazing
characters and i wanted to do some of
that and i wanted to make something that
felt
also hopeful it's a very hopeful story
it's about
love and affection for those who look
after you and
those who protect you and it's about a
celebration of
sense of community so i just felt this
is something that
feels that i want to make for now really
and it's a film
i want all generations to feel to get
something out of when it came out in the
uk
we we had a lot of whole families going
to see it and
and different generations taking
something different from it
um about wanting to discuss it with each
generation in the family
yeah that's interesting too because
you're talking about different
generations watching it too and
that's what's going to wonder about like
the pg rating right can you kind of go
into
kind of the decision making for that and
the kind of the pros and cons you faced
with doing a pg film
yeah i mean it wasn't you know it wasn't
a decision i didn't
i i i wanted to make something that was
true to the book but
the book is something that i think
appeals to all
generations i also wanted to make a film
where you weren't required to know
anything about the book or afraid or
whatever it's just there as an
entertainment
i felt it was important that everyone
felt they could come and see the film
it's not a children's film it's a film
that children and you know teenagers and
then
adults of all generations and ages will
get something from and can connect with
and therefore i thought it was important
that we didn't um you know there's no
swearing in such
which there is a little bit of in the
death of stalin i mean
um could he didn't read it it didn't
require it didn't feel
like that was the kind of world that i
was
showing really i wanted to do something
that
fell um almost kind of magical in in a
kind of theatrical way in that
you know if if things visually happen in
an
unusual way on screen i didn't want to
do them with cgi
and kind of special effects like that
because i think
i think they're no longer magic you know
i think we're so used to them that they
don't surprise us
so whenever there was something that
visually
had to happen that that was special i
wanted to do it for real you know we try
to construct it in a way that it
physically happened in front of you
so you know backdrops fall and suddenly
you're on a cliff
or you're transported somewhere else or
by the use of a mirror you suddenly see
something you know all these things that
again
i think again going by the reaction to
it in the uk
families have have responded to in a way
that
they haven't to to to cgi no yeah
for sure and also like a reaction i've
seen to the film so far is
a lot of people are talking about the
casting choice in particular
you you know you didn't go with all
white actors in this victorian piece
it's a bold choice and i think it's a
great choice and also having
dev patel as david copperfield who's an
older actor playing a younger david
copperfield so
what's your case for these decisions
against the naysayers who
may say oh that's not totally
historically accurate or not what they
want to see like
what do you combat that with well
i mean historically accurate it's a
fiction novel
it didn't actually happen i want people
watching the film
to see themselves in the film i want the
characters in the film to feel that they
are living in their present day
it might be 1840 in the film but for
them
that's the present so they should feel
alive
i could only think of dev to play david
he for me
embodied the spirit of david copperfield
you know he's the comedy the tragedy the
romance the charisma
the platforms the visual comedy the the
impressions that he did the mimicry
uh the romance everything death to me
was was
was was david and i really didn't think
about
the fact that he you know has a is from
an indian background
he just felt to me he embodied the
character
and once dev said yes i thought that's
how we should cast everyone
you know find the person who fills the
character
right and this is something that's been
going on in theater
for decades now and and i don't know why
film is so literal um if we are going to
still make films
set in the past as a sort of
period drama industry for goodness sake
we have to be able to
cast from 100 of the acting talent
that's out there
we can't be saying to a whole group of
actors sorry this isn't for you
um and and you mentioned that people are
talking about the casting
it's interesting people talk about the
casting before they see the film
and when after they've seen the film
they don't talk about the catholics
because they feel
that the people they've seen on screen
are naturally right for the part you
know
yeah absolutely so it's an interesting
and interesting thing it's an
interesting thing
yeah absolutely and that's that's a
really awesome answer and i think it's
you make such an awesome point too about
how like theater's kind of ahead in this
where like for some reason film like you
said it's so literal and
i don't understand but this is good that
you're making a film that's breaking
those barriers more and more so
that is commendable so another thing to
want to ask you is
you've written so many things in your
career and you're such a talented
screenwriter but
do you still find in doing an adaptation
things you connect in the story to your
own personal views and what comes from
oh absolutely what drew me to this
because it's about
someone you know that it is personal
it's about someone growing up
trying to work out who they are and in
the end they just
realize they're a writer and you know
i've spent most of my career thinking
yes but i this isn't my real job is it
you know i i mean
you know i i'm feeling almost kind of
you know embarrassed that i'm getting
through life
doing something that i really enjoy and
that you know at some point i ought to
sit down and
do a proper job and then realizing no
this is my proper job
you know this is actually what i've been
doing for the last 30 years so i might
as well accept it
so that appealed to me as well as you
know reconnecting me
with my you know early love of of
dickens and
and his kind of um i see i think
when you read early dickens he's a
precursor to charlie chaplin
really um you know by the age of 24
dickens was the most famous writer in
the world
you know in america they would wait down
in the harbor
for the new monthly editions of his
novel to come in
because they were desperate to find out
what happened next and sin the chaplain
chaplain went over to america and by the
age of 23 24
he was the most famous man in the world
basically uh you know everyone knew
chaplain
and and what he did with looking at the
you know you know the common individual
stories of poverty against riches and
society and
you know modern times and you know the
big things but the little guy in
the middle of it are so decentralian
really um
so chaplain and dickens are part of the
same kind of tradition
yeah and i i totally see that connection
and with us as the audience watching
this film and scene connection now a
blend of dickens but with
armando yanucci's spin on it if you're
looking at it as a whole
and what you directed and what you wrote
what would you say
is the one thing this film is trying to
say
oh heavens it's that well first of all
it's an entertainment i hope people just
leave
feeling at the end of it feeling a lot
happier about themselves
and about those they love really it's a
celebration of community
so with that is it also encouraging to
go away and read the book or to read
about the time
or or just to read then that's great
um but it's funny about that i want
people to feel
good about themselves really especially
if they've
had to experience adversity or if
they've
felt for one way or another they don't
quite fit in
see that as a plus see that as a marker
being
kind of their individuality really yeah
i love that
i i totally feel that after i watch the
film and it it isn't
good to see movies like this especially
in the times we're living right now that
are uplifting and give hope and for
anything we're all facing as just
people together so i think it really is
effective in that sense so before i let
you go armando
i wanted to ask in your brilliant mind
is there anything you got brewing coming
up that we can look forward to
or any plugs you want to put in before i
let you go well we're about to start
shooting season two of avenue five
very much affected by the last six or so
months we've all been through
of isolation and madness uh
will be coming through loud and clear in
season two
awesome and armando i can't wait people
see this film today everybody it is
out for digital release and it's also
still playing in many theaters
so make sure to check it out it is
definitely worth the watch
armando i hope you have a great rest of
your day and stay safe in yourself
isolation i hope to talk to you again
soon thank you very much thank you